let's speak to mr burko now to get his
reaction and mr burko from the start you
have denied
any of the claims made against you given
the reports findings today that you're a
serial liar and a serial bully are you
reflecting differently on the actions
that you took while in the house of
commons
thank you sarah jane now i'm not
reflecting differently on them at all i
regard it as a kangaroo court the
process has been protracted
kafkaesque and completely unjust
as far as i'm concerned i have told the
truth
from the start of the investigation to
its finish i'm very sorry that in
pursuit of headlines in a very
chock-a-block media environment the
independent expert panel has chosen to
use language that is unloyally
which is intemperate and which is
hyperbolic i accept that they have a
right to make a decision but i am not
obliged to accept that its decision is
right it isn't and i don't
mr burkey we do interrupt our continuing
coverage of ukraine because this is
important standards in public life are
being talked about a lot given what's
going on in the current government
obviously events in ukraine are
overshadowing that but we're revisiting
it because of the independent complaints
and grievance schemes findings you call
it a kangaroo court but this is a
committee that was chaired by a former
law justice of appeal and chairman of
the bar
it also gathered evidence that would
have been the same evidence gathered
in civil law
and this was a scheme set up to clean up
standards in public life to hold public
figures like yourself to account so for
you to call it a kangaroo court today
undermines all the work that's being
done in politics to try and write itself
no i don't accept that at all i think we
need to be absolutely clear the
so-called independent expert panel
wasn't studying the cases it was the
sanctions body and if you like the body
to which one could appeal huge swathes
of evidence were ignored by that panel
hearsay was preferred over the testimony
of people it wasn't here
it was following processes and standard
proof required by civil law everyone
involved and
everyone involved including yourself had
access to legal advice just looking at
some of the findings of the report some
of the complaints were supported by the
evidence of notebook entries and to a
significant extent by other witnesses
however john burko tried to refute the
content of the notes he was not able to
do so the evidence from them is
compelling and therefore the report was
bound to conclude that the respondent
has lied extensively to try and avoid
the thrust of these allegations
no well you're just reading from the
report which of course sergeant you're
absolutely entitled to do but what i'm
saying to you
yes and if you'd be kind enough to allow
me to reply i will
thank you the answer is that i don't
accept any of the aggressive territory
here which i don't want to so please
continue no we're not getting into any
no we're not getting into any passive
aggressive territory as far as i'm
concerned what i would say to you is
very simply this hearsay that is to say
the testimony of people who were not
present was preferred over the testimony
of people present an allegation was made
for example
you're calling it hearsay and the fact
i'm sorry you can't be a witness to
something which you didn't attend and
when witnesses present said no
i do not accept that allegation that did
not happen the investigators chose
instead to accept testimony from people
who had heard second or third hand okay
i'll bring you some testimony from
someone who was there one one of those
who accused you of bullying and they
said there was talk of um there was
shouting fish shaking and throwing
things it details an incident where a
mobile phone was thrown or john burko
was standing over me and it burst into
hundreds of bits i could feel them
hitting me it was the most violent
extraordinary display of temper that's
not hearsay that's direct evidence from
somebody involved do you feel that your
language or actions were appropriate in
your as it's described in the report
your extraordinary position of power
forgive me sarah jane you're just
repeating an allegation with which i had
already dealt but i'm very happy to
address it yes a complainant claims that
i threw a phone when the witness who was
allegedly brought in to pick up the
pieces was asked about it that witness
did not repeat not corroborate the
allegation there was a second allegation
that i had thrown a phone and in that
respect the person with whom i'd been in
a meeting was asked for his testimony
and he said categorically in terms
unmistakable that i had not done so so i
stand by my point that the people who
were supposedly witnesses at the event
said no
this did not happen there were twenty
the decision makers have chosen to
conclude that it did
21 complaints no because i
thank you sarah sarah jen thank you very
much indeed for the question but the
answer is no and i'll tell you why
because i don't believe in faux
apologies this is a flawed process it's
chronically unjust it appertains to
matters up to 12 and a half years ago
from next month as i'm sure your viewers
will want to know
the bullying process the investigative
process will apply
only to matters reported that occurred
within 12 months okay so 12 months from
april and i'm being judged against 12
years the evidence is set up at that
time
we keep hearing that parliament doesn't
have an hr department it doesn't have
the due process for complaints to be
made
when that scheme was introduced they
then came forward but let me just put
this to you is there a chance that
perhaps you bullied people without
realizing because
a lot of the time bullies don't realize
their bullying
that is certainly the case but the fact
is no i don't accept that because there
are two criteria sarah jane in the
assessment of bullying whether somebody
felt bullied and whether he or she was
reasonably justified in feeling bullied
now people can say what they will about
how they felt but in terms of an
objective assessment of the evidence
there is no reasonable basis for
concluding that i bullied anyone i
repeat that i do not believe there's any
serious evidence and let me put it to
you like this there is no video evidence
there is no audio evidence there is no
email evidence there is no text evidence
there is here evidence preferred
do you plan to appeal and is it right
that you've been suspended from the
labour party today
i'm not going to get into the matter of
the labor party that's a decision for
them which i'm happy to respect and with
which i'm not going to argue on the
matter of appeal that matters has
already been dealt with by the process
of which i think you are aware okay john
berkey thank you for your time